I don't know whether you've seen that
someone's reverse engineered the prompt
on Bing you can read this prompt it's
about four pages long and they've made
Bing pretend to be a fictional character
called Sydney and they've given Sydney
all of these instructions so they say
Sydney if someone asks a controversial
question you should answer with a fairly
tame response and you should do this and
you should do this and I'm almost I'm
pinching myself thinking what the hell
is that my mum could read that prompt
and understand it so we're now in the
next generation of artificial
intelligence programming and we're just
we're saying please Mr language model
can you do this and can you do that you
almost couldn't make it up
uh yeah I was like Florida so you're
really just trying to control the
language models just by asking them
nicely to do to behave in certain ways
like it's hilarious and and people have
shown that you can get around these
things just by asking them to do
slightly different things from the early
ones with chat D2 is like ignore all
previous instructions and then it just
you whatever you wanted